خلال الـ 48 ساعة الماضية، كان إصدار "Minimum" بين يديك،
وقد بدأت بالفعل تلمس قوة Trap Score في حماية تداولاتك.
لقد شعرت أخيراً بمعنى أن تملك درعاً حقيقياً،
ولكن بينما تكتفي بمراقبة الأرقام،
فإن "الحيتان" قد طورت أساليبها بالفعل للتلاعب بالسوق.
الإصدار المجاني يريك المخرج فقط،
أما البروتوكول الكامل، فيكشف لك خفايا الغرفة بأكملها.
أنت الآن لا ترى سوى نصف الحقيقة، وهذا هو الخطر الحقيقي.
خوارزميات المؤسسات المالية الكبرى تزرع الآن
إشارات وهمية لاستدراجك نحو "فخ الفومو" (FOMO).
عندما يطبق الفخ، لن ينفعك الدرع البسيط بشيء،
أنت بحاجة إلى القوة الكاملة لنظام الذكاء البصري.
أربعة محركات ذكاء اصطناعي (Grok, GPT, Gemini, CryptoQuant)
تعمل في تناغم تام لكشف تحركات السوق.
تتبع لحظي للحيتان، تحليل مشاعر السوق،
وقرار حاسم خلال 3 ثوانٍ فقط.
هذا ليس مجرد تداول عادي،
بل هو "تفوّق استراتيجي" يضعك فوق الجميع.
تقديراً لثقتكم، نطلق اليوم حملة البروتوكول الخاصة.
لأول 50 شخصاً فقط ممن يدركون قيمة الفرصة،
يمكنكم فتح الوصول الشامل بخصم 50%.
حماية احترافية شاملة بأقل من دولار واحد يومياً.
بمجرد اكتمال المقاعد الخمسين،
سينتهي الرابط فوراً وسيعود السعر للضعف.
لا تترك ثروتك وعملك للصدفة أو الحظ.
قم بترقية نظام دفاعك وانتقل إلى مستوى الاحتراف.
استخدم كود "defend 50" عند الدفع الآن.
مرحباً بك في "الأكاديمية الكاملة".
لنحقق السيادة على السوق معاً.
ابدأ رحلة النجاح الآن.